Now I mentioned we're going to make some modifications to the crowd system.
So first thing I want to slow down the characters so they're not running around.
And to do that let's go to crowd character blueprint.
And we're going to go to the character movement component.
Let's search for max walk speed.
Currently it's set to 600.
Now we've already talked about blend spaces but let's revisit that concept so we can pick a good value so it's walking comfortably.
So if I go to third person example map and go to mannequin animations, double click on third person idle run 2D.
And then let's just hover over these values.
OK so I have a feeling 93.75 is going to be what we want because that is where the third person walk animation is introduced.
If it's zero he's idling.
If it's 375 he's running.
And if the value is 600 he's definitely running.
So if you just drag back and forth you can test what the animation would look like at different values.
But I'm definitely going to do 93.75.
So I will close that.
And go back to crowd character.
And let's change the value to 93.75.
OK hit save.
And then if you remember last time these crowd characters they moved once and then they stopped.
So let's go ahead and add the repeat functionality before we test this again.
So let's go to crowd controller.
And what I want to do is just have this move happen over and over again with a little bit of a delay in between.
So it's actually really easy to set up.
You don't have to know about for loops and things like that.
So if I left click drag off of the execution and I just type in delay and it's not the retriggerable delay it's the straight up delay.
Let's add that node.
And I'm going to drag it up and above the simple move to location because what I'm going to do is say OK once this delay is completed go right back into the move.
And then delay and then move and continue that process until we're not in play mode anymore.
Now point two seconds that's a little fast.
I'm going to change that to two seconds and let's test this compile save.
Go back to third person example map hit play.
OK we've got some people walking around and they're moving all at the same time.
So they look a little too synchronized.
But we can fix that.
So if we go back to crowd controller one more thing I'm going to add I'm going to drag off of the duration input and type in random float in range.
So it generates a random number between a minute and Max and floats are just numbers that have decimal points.
So let's say OK between two and five seconds.
OK so that way the delays are a little bit offset breaks it up a bit.
So we'll do compile save.
Go back to third person example map hit play.
Let's take a look.
OK he moved but the other character didn't so I'd say it's working.
All right so we've set up the crowd simulation we've made adjustments and in the next video we're going to introduce the power of take recorder.